(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre os leilões
da Justiça do Trabalho.
Como eu falei anteriormente aqui no curso, os
leilões judiciais podem ser realizados por qualquer juiz
e esses juízes podem integrar a Justiça Comum,
que é a Justiça Estadual, a Justiça Federal
e a Justiça do Trabalho.
A gente acabou de falar na aula anterior
sobre preço vil e eu falei que quem
estipula o que é preço vil é o
Código de Processo Civil.
E esse Código de Processo Civil é a
lei que traz as regras dos leilões judiciais,
exceto algumas regras da Justiça do Trabalho.
Por que isso acontece?
A Justiça do Trabalho tem lei própria.
Essa lei é a SLT e ela traz
disposições de matéria trabalhista e de matéria processual
trabalhista.
Então, nada impede que um juiz do trabalho
leve a leilão algum imóvel de um devedor
para que esse imóvel vire dinheiro e assim
pagar débitos trabalhistas que aquele devedor possui e
que estavam sendo discutidos na Justiça do Trabalho.
Então, vamos lá.
A SLT tem normas materiais de direito do
trabalho e normas processuais que devem ser aplicadas
nos processos judiciais trabalhistas.
E a SLT fala que ela aplica o
CPC, que é o Código de Processo Civil,
de maneira subsidiária.
Então, o juiz trabalhista pode se socorrer de
alguma norma que está prevista no Código de
Processo Civil se a SLT não falar nada
sobre determinada situação e se o que o
Código de Processo Civil falar sobre determinada situação
for compatível com a Justiça do Trabalho.
E aqui é o que eu quero falar
para vocês sobre o preço vil nos leilões
da Justiça do Trabalho.
A disposição que a gente acabou de ver
na aula anterior, que se um imóvel for
arrematado por menos de 50% do laudo
de avaliação, que ele vai ser considerado preço
vil e que aquilo pode anular aquele leilão,
não se aplica aos leilões da Justiça do
Trabalho e não se aplica justamente por isso,
porque a Justiça do Trabalho aplica a SLT
e não o Código de Processo Civil.
Ela só aplica o Código de Processo Civil
naquilo que a SLT não falar e no
que for compatível com o processo judicial trabalhista.
E a SLT não fala sobre preço vil.
Ela não fala percentual de preço vil.
Então, você pode pensar, se ela não fala,
o juiz poderia recorrer ao Código de Processo
Civil para saber o que é preço vil
ou não.
Isso não ocorre na Justiça trabalhista, porque a
Justiça trabalhista considera que esse percentual de 50%,
que é considerado preço vil na Justiça comum
e na Justiça federal, não se aplica aos
processos trabalhistas e não se aplica por quê?
Porque processos trabalhistas discutem débitos trabalhistas e esses
débitos trabalhistas são chamados de créditos alimentares, ou
seja, o trabalhador efetivamente precisa receber o valor
daquele crédito trabalhista para que ele possa continuar
vivendo.
É um crédito que deve ser pago com
a máxima urgência possível, porque ele é um
crédito alimentar.
O trabalhador precisa daquele dinheiro até mesmo para
comer.
Então, a Justiça do Trabalho, pelo menos em
tese, deve ser a mais rápida possível, justamente
para que o trabalhador possa receber de forma
a mais rápida possível o valor que ele
tem de crédito trabalhista, de crédito alimentar.
Então, por isso que a Justiça do Trabalho
entende que essa disposição do Código de Processo
Civil de falar que o imóvel é arrematado
por menos de 50% do valor de
sua avaliação vai ser considerado preço vil, não
se aplica para o processo trabalhista, porque o
processo trabalhista, se acontecer um leilão, aquele leilão
tem que acontecer da forma a mais rápida
possível para que o imóvel vire dinheiro da
forma a mais rápida possível e o trabalhador
possa receber da forma a mais rápida possível.
Então, nesse ponto, a Justiça do Trabalho entende
que não se aplica essa conceituação de preço
vil, que é 50% do valor de
avaliação para os processos trabalhistas.
E o que acontece na prática?
Na prática, a gente vê imóveis sendo levados
a leilão pela Justiça do Trabalho serem arrematados
por 30, 40% do valor de avaliação.
E tudo bem, porque esse imóvel está sendo
levado a leilão pela Justiça do Trabalho e
a Justiça do Trabalho não aplica aquele percentual
de preço vil que aplica o Código de
Processo Civil que a gente estudou na aula
anterior.
Então, provavelmente, o juiz do trabalho vai homologar
aquele leilão judicial, mesmo que aquele leilão judicial
tenha um lance por menos de 50%
da avaliação do imóvel, porque ele tem pressa
em pagar aqueles credores.
Então, aquele leilão não cabe uma alegação de
preço vil.
E você pode pensar, eu falei na aula
anterior, que o Código de Processo Civil passado
não tinha esse percentual de 50% que
define o que é ou não preço vil
e que isso gerava uma margem de recursos
para que o executado, quem está perdendo o
imóvel, pudesse tentar anular aquele leilão.
E aí, você pode trazer esse mesmo pensamento
e falar assim, se a Justiça do Trabalho
aplica a CLT, se a CLT não fala
em que é preço vil e se a
Justiça do Trabalho entende que não pode aplicar
o que é preço vil do Código de
Processo Civil, então o executado na Justiça do
Trabalho também vai apresentar recurso tentando anular esse
leilão da Justiça do Trabalho, falar que foi
por um preço vil, correto?
Não, isso não acontece na Justiça do Trabalho.
A Justiça do Trabalho é muito dura com
a homologação dos leilões, ou seja, ela homologa
os leilões e para anular é muito difícil,
exatamente porque a Justiça do Trabalho está discutindo
um débito de um trabalhador e esse trabalhador
precisa receber o mais rápido possível porque esse
dinheiro envolve até mesmo o dinheiro que ele
usa para se alimentar, o dinheiro de moradia,
então ele tem pressa para receber.
Então, é muito difícil que um leilão da
Justiça do Trabalho seja anulado, é muito difícil
que o juiz aceite qualquer tipo de delegação
tentando anular o leilão realizado na Justiça do
Trabalho.
E mais um parêntese, a Justiça do Trabalho
tem toda uma sistemática própria de recursos, não
é que nem o Código de Processo Civil.
A CLT, então, dispõe dos recursos que serão
aplicados na Justiça do Trabalho e esses recursos
também têm uma dinâmica diferente, então realmente o
executado não teria esse campo para interpor um
recurso tentando anular o leilão como acontece com
a disposição do Código de Processo Civil.
A CLT é diferente.
Eu separei aqui um leilão da Justiça do
Trabalho para a gente ver como é diferente
e como está tudo bem ser diferente em
relação ao preço vil.
Esse leilão que a gente vai estudar, ele
está aqui, ele foi realizado por um leiloeiro
em novembro de 2019.
Valor da avaliação, R$ 425.800. Lance
mínimo, R$ 170.320. Ele foi arrematado
exatamente pelo lance mínimo, quer dizer, a pessoa
levou pelo lance mínimo.
E o valor do lance mínimo correspondia a
40% da avaliação desse imóvel.
E ok, porque é Justiça do Trabalho.
Justiça do Trabalho cabe essa exceção.
Não se aplica o preço vil, não se
aplica o percentual de 50% do valor
da avaliação como se aplica na Justiça Comum
e na Justiça Federal.
Para saber se um leilão é da Justiça
Estadual, que é chamada Justiça Comum, se é
da Justiça Federal ou se é da Justiça
do Trabalho, basta olhar o edital daquele leilão.
O edital do leilão vai falar qual é
a justiça que está determinando.
Então, nesse caso aqui específico, se a gente
subir um pouco, tem Leilão Judicial Unificado do
TRT.
TRT é sigla de Tribunal Regional do Trabalho.
Então, esse leilão aqui foi um leilão realizado
pelo Justiça do Trabalho.
Foi um leilão arrematado pelo valor mínimo e
o valor mínimo correspondia a 40% da
avaliação.
E tudo bem, esse leilão foi homologado.
Quem arrematou levou o imóvel por 40%
da avaliação.
Qual é a consequência disso para você interessar
em arrematar o imóvel em leilão?
Pode ser muito interessante arrematar o imóvel de
um leilão da Justiça do Trabalho.
Exatamente por quê?
O valor que vai ser concedido de desconto
pode ser bem maior do que um valor
concedido na Justiça Estadual ou na Justiça Federal,
porque Justiça Estadual e Justiça Federal aplicam preço
vil.
Será considerado preço vil valor inferior a 50
% do valor da avaliação do imóvel.
Justiça do Trabalho não aplica preço vil.
Então, Justiça do Trabalho tem pressa para vender
aquele bem, tem pressa para pagar o trabalhador.
Então, o juiz pode determinar um percentual de
30%, 40% do valor da avaliação do
imóvel e homologar aquele leilão e tudo certo
com aquele leilão.
Então, saiba que pode ser muito interessante ser
participado na Justiça do Trabalho, mas que a
justiça que mais leva imóvel a leilão judicial
disparado é a Justiça Estadual, também chamada de
Justiça Comum.
Leilões de Justiça Federal e de Justiça do
Trabalho são um pouco mais raros, mas acontecem
e trazem grandes oportunidades.